I think the toy party has to settle down
and get on with delivering its mandate
that it was elected on in 2019 with a
massive majority which is to govern on
behalf of the citizens of this country
and I think that means tackling the
economic challenges we Face tackling the
threats globally that we face and I'm
make sure that's the real number one
priority for us all
running in this leadership race last
time I said I wouldn't stand it was not
something that I was prepared to do it
you think you really have to want it as
a prime minister to do that job you have
to really really think it's the job for
you for me I feel that I can add the
best value in keeping people safe at
defense by being the defense secretary
it's the job that I have been doing and
it's the job I intend to stay doing so I
am not going to be standing for prime
minister this time and the same reasons
really apply as last time
can you tell us who you would be putting
your weight behind well I think it's
really important to consider for me
which candidate will recognize the very
pressing security concerns that face
this country at the time that will take
decisions to invest in defense and
security it's really important without
you know National Security there is no
Economic Security and I think that is
important that whoever are the
candidates between aim forward they
indicate that but also at the same time
I have to recognize the issue of the
Mandate this is will be our potentially
our third prime minister since the
general election of 2019 that means we
have to think about that legitimacy
question that the public will be asking
themselves and also about who could win
the next election that's obviously
important for any political party at the
time so you know at the moment I would
lean towards Boris Johnson I think he
will still have some questions to answer
around obviously that investigation but
I know when I was such a safe to fancy
invested in fence he supported me he
supported the actions this country has
taken to keep us safe so that's at the
moment I'm leaning towards that but I
think you know there are a few days to
go go and we'll see what's happened
there's some you know other candidates
who are just as excellent putting their
name in the ring but I think
fundamentally we have to answer those
first two points they said earlier
so we would not be supporting then the
candidacy of Rishi sunak well I think
what I've said is at the moment I'm
leaning towards Boris Johnson you know
I'll be Keen to see what Richardson also
says on defense and security and
investment and I think it's just
important to reiterate to your viewers
there can't be Economic Security without
National Security and therefore you know
those candidates need to answer that
question as much as what they're going
to do in the here and now about the
economy do you know whether Mr Johnson
would be in favor of keeping defense the
commitment to keeping defense spending
at three percent of GDP for the in the
next decade well his track record is
definitely off investing in defense he
gave me an extra 24 billion pounds uh
into defense when other departments
weren't getting a multi-year settlement
at the time and I think that shows his
actions were obviously uh you know his
true colors on that and I think we just
have to continue looking at the impacts
of the economic situation but you know
the direction of travel has to be an
increased investment in defense and
certainly recognizing that there are
real threats to this country and you
know there's not a a day that goes by
without me working on that and you know
I am in a position where I see those
threats often the public can't see them
I'm afraid because of intelligence but
nonetheless they are real and I'll look
for a candidate and a leader that can do
that Boris Johnson has to date always
had that track record and that's why
I'll be leaning towards him at the
moment do you not think that Mr Johnson
though is Tainted by previous scandals
and that the electorate really wouldn't
go for that well let's see in 2019 he
won a general election with a huge
majority you know he was legitimately
sent into Parliament as the Prime
Minister based on the vote of the whole
electorate not just on touring members
not just on members of parliament that
he got a mandate and I think that's an
important thing for all of us to bear in
mind we'll see what happens of course
Unity is also important you know I'll be
looking for how the candidates are
prepared to bring the party together
because without Unity we can't govern
either
but some would say that Mr Johnson would
be even more divisive because it seems
that a number of MPS have said that they
will resign the whip if he becomes the
candidate we've seen uh sadly from the
last leadership election the party had
lots of finalists uh they were not it
wasn't a clear winner Head and Shoulders
above the other that of course is cause
for concern and here we are back again
I'm afraid and and you know last time
they didn't choose uh you know they
didn't choose others they chose Liz
truss I would have hoped that we'd all
settle down given people some space
delivered a new budget that hasn't
happened so therefore we have to
recognize we have to focus on Unity we
have to focus on who's best a place to
win the next election as well do you
think it's realistic for there to be a
Halloween budget given that the new
leader will only be in place two days
before this budget takes place well look
I I think the timing of the budget is
incredibly important when it comes to
you know the advice you get from the
treasury the treasury has to make sure
that it keeps confidence in
International markets and if if that
deems a budget on the 31st October then
that is what potentially has to happen
but I'll leave that decision to the
chancellor who has the best interests of
the economy at his heart I think any
potential leader is going to have to
really work hard with Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor is it really Jeremy Hunt
who's still going to be in charge well I
hope Jeremy stays as a Chancellor he I
had a meeting with him yesterday Jeremy
is like me a very experienced member of
the government he joined with me in 2005
he is calm he is experienced he's
knowledgeable about all needs to be done
and you know I have a lot of faith in
him being our Chancellor and how
realistic is it do you think of any of
these candidates to get 100 votes how
many candidates do you think will be
able to achieve that well we've got over
350 MPS I think that is possible uh you
know we've got between now and Monday
and I think we'll get on with it